y os voy a pedir que levanten la mano
los que consideren que la imagen detrás
mío corresponde a una obra de arte
no hay lugar a dudas no qué pasa con
esta otra
podrá gustarnos más o menos depende de
los gustos estéticos pero nadie se va a
realizar por ver un mondrian en un museo
qué ocurre si los muestro un urinario
empiezan las dudas no es cualquier
urinario la fuente presentado por tussam
para ingresar en una exhibición de arte
donde todas las obras iban a ser
aceptadas y esta que va afuera los otros
comisionados que tenían que decidir que
entraba la dejaron de lado
dusán pronunció una obra de arte
conceptual irreverente y políticamente
incorrecta porque a veces el arte
también se trata de eso
y esta otra
una caja de polvo de lavar y ni siquiera
la auténtica una réplica pero si les
digo que es de warhol
las caras se empiezan a cambiar un
nombre que valida otra obra icono de las
vanguardias del siglo 20 en este caso un
arte que nos habla de lo que está
sucediendo de de arte comercial de sus
arte de élite porque porque el arte no
es siempre algo lindo el arte no es
siempre un cuadro de hecho en sus
orígenes el arte fue mucho más que de
solarte fue ritual el arte fue política
fue comunicación
por eso el arte a veces puede ser
efímero puede ser brutal puede realizar
nos como marina abramovic y sus
performance que buscan con modernos que
buscan comentar algo contar que son
declaraciones políticas sociales
religiosas a veces o el arte puede
aliarse con la ciencia y crear una
coneja como alva una que oreja
fosforescente cuya paternidad se estuvo
en debate entre el artista eduardo cat y
el laboratorio que la encargó es un
descubrimiento es una obra de arte
con esto en mente quienes dirían que una
imagen como ésta puede ser arte que un
videojuego capaz es una de las nuevas
vanguardias como lo fue en su momento de
sant o como lo fue en su momento warhol
y no le estoy diciendo yo ni tampoco lo
dice un grupo de geeks fanatizados que
se pasan 24 horas al día y que conocen
todos los trucos que pueden haber no es
algo que está sucediendo en el mundo y
que lo están validando instituciones e
instituciones desde el arte y desde la
tecnología museos con el smithsonian le
dedico a este año una exhibición de
varios meses a la historia del
videojuego la influencia el videojuego
en la cultura y los que elegían las
obras que tienen que estar en exhibición
en el propio público o por ejemplo un
museo de la tecnología como es el de
berlín tiene un ala enteramente dedicada
a lo que son videojuegos desde la
consola primera hasta de realizaciones
contemporáneas hechas por artistas que
trabajan en torno al dispositivo
videojuegos
y por qué no también festivales como al
pse electrónica un festival que se
realizan a otras en austria que es
paradigmático de lo que es arte y
tecnología tiene una categoría que se
llama arte interactivo y que viene
premiando hace rato videojuegos
videojuegos comerciales y los dos
independientes dispositivos creados para
artistas son distintas formas en las que
el videojuego puede llegar a ser
considerado arte no digo que todos lo
sean pero algunos sí y esto sucede y era
inevitable que sucediera porque el arte
es algo propio del hombre el arte es una
forma que tenemos de expresarnos de
comunicar de transmitir emociones el
arte va cambiando en cada época con cada
sociedad valiéndose de distintas
herramientas la tecnología en este siglo
era inevitable y el videojuego es una de
las tantas caras que puede llegar a
tomar y estas son una de las tantas
caras que están detrás de estas
creaciones
estos son quizás los próximos jugar solo
son los que están caminando entre
nosotros nosotros somos quienes vamos a
decir si puede ser arte
y el tiempo después nos dará uno la
razón les propongo hacer un rápido paneo
por seis casos de videojuegos que
probablemente no sean todavía una mona
lisa o una caja como las brilló box de
warhol pero que están sentando las bases
de lo que está por venir la forma más
rápida quizás que tenemos de acercarnos
es el cine el videojuego como un paso
más del séptimo arte al octavo ahora
interactividad a lo que el arte desde
que se sale de la tela está buscando de
ciertas ramas del arte buscan
comprometer al otro correrlo del lugar
del observador engancharlo hacerlo
protagonista el videojuego lo tiene de
por sí casos como este hasta se inscribe
un videojuego mainstream que puede ser
vapuleado para aquellos más indies pero
que tiene mucho por detrás son tres años
de trabajo 500 personas desarrollando
departamentos dedicados a fotografía
diseño de personajes a narrativa hasta
se reconstrucción de italia renacentista
se trabajó con historiadores con
arquitectos con especialistas en esta
época la única forma que tenemos hoy de
recorrer estos lugares
hace poco una muestra en el museo de
arte decorativo sobre cuadros de esa
época colas y colas interminables por
tener un acercamiento a esa distancia
acá es lo mismo
nos están llevando por un recorrido
donde nosotros somos quienes transitamos
esa historia somos los protagonistas de
este cuento y así como hollywood tiene
una contracara que puede ser cansó el
oso de berlín con propuestas que buscan
contar otra historia transmitir otras
experiencias que tienen otro circuito
también lo tienen los videojuegos con
empresas que se presentan como puramente
artísticas es el caso de thatgamecompany
una empresa californiana que dice que
desarrolla videojuegos que son como
podemos interactivos este es su último
trabajo germain el viaje de lerna
retomado por toda narrativa cualquier
libro o película que vean habla de esto
acá es un viaje propio a cada uno nos
despertamos en el desierto solos en la
inmensidad sin nadie que nos acompañe y
una luz a la cual seguir
el viaje el significado va a ser propio
a cada uno es ingresar en un cuadro es
ingresar en un poema es ser un el que
camina por esos versos y a veces aparece
otro personaje que es una persona que
está conectada en ese preciso momento
que está transitando su propio camino su
propio destino y que se conecta con
nosotros a través de sonidos no tenemos
un lenguaje conocido no podemos chatear
emitimos sonidos cantamos nos
comunicamos nos acompañamos y cuando
desaparece sacar una cosita nos quedamos
solos haciendo este camino
hasta que todo sencillo parece es
estética lo entendemos no es tan loco
pero qué pasa si nos ponemos un poquito
más experimentales daniel benmergui
argentino trabaja con la narrativa cómo
se cuenta una historia el retoma en este
caso las teorías de los constructivistas
rusos se metió consignadas
story teller cuentacuentos ganó el nuevo
a word en la ig efe independent game
conference del festival de este año el
premio por antonomasia en lo que es ser
experimental en un videojuego él nos
plantea en el lenguaje de historietas un
cuentacuentos en este caso
adam debe morir no tenemos nada me llena
la vida si ponemos adame en la primera
viñeta y a la lápida en la segunda capo
todas a veces se inspira en citas del
cine como cualquier propuesta indecente
tenemos esta feliz pareja si le ponemos
un cofre la pareja se romperá a depende
de nosotros cual hacer la decisión de
nuestro protagonista si elige el amor o
el dinero está experimentando nos podrá
parecer arte o no lo veremos pero está
sucediendo
y el arte como dijimos hoy puede ser
también político norte puede tener un
mensaje fuerte que transmitir en algún
momento los muralistas de méxico
salieron a las calles sino en las calles
hablar de política educar al pueblo a
concientizar sobre lo que estaba
sucediendo aquí con solo frasca desde
uruguay nos plantea septiembre 12
inspirado los sucesos de septiembre o se
nos mete en un pueblo cualquiera en
medio oriente civiles caminando y entre
ellos personas armadas una mira no hay
objetivos no hay ninguna regla depende
de nosotros que hacer nuestro primer
instinto matar al malo pero entre que
disparemos y el misil llegue
va a haber heridos que no tenían que
hacer los que tenían que caer los
civiles se van a acercar a llorar a sus
familiares muertos y se van a compartir
esos también en terroristas violencia
engendra violencia es simple pero que
nos lo digan no es lo mismo que tomar
conciencia al ser nosotros los
responsables de esas acciones
si les ganas juegos que tienen que ver
con la realidad social con lo que nos
está pasando
el videojuego acercándose a la educación
el videojuego como una herramienta para
conectarnos con los pequeños que ya
nacen con un site prácticamente
o un videojuego experimental
desarrollado en este caso por un músico
dix y una escafandra una máscara de gas
que nos aísla totalmente lo que tenemos
alrededor de unos auriculares estamos en
el fondo del mar nuestra misión es de
escapar de unas bestias salvajes que nos
están persiguiendo tenemos el recurso de
un joystick y el sonido que escuchamos
la experiencia en algún momento el arte
cuando se corría del cuadro empezó a
trabajar con el cuerpo con las emociones
con los sentimientos y las sensaciones
surgieron las performance y los
happenings transitar algo apelar a otras
sensibilidades marta minujín es un icono
acá seguramente escucharon hablar de la
menesunda uno recorrido una suerte de
escenario donde sucedían cosas era un
paso más que lo visual era atravesar la
experiencia con el cuerpo pero seguíamos
siendo testigos acá somos protagonistas
y además se abren posibilidades para
gente por ejemplo no vidente la
propuesta es justamente empezar a
trabajar con todas estas capacidades que
tenemos
finalmente tengo station desarrollado
por artistas dentro de su tesis para
recibirse en la universidad retoma en el
juego del pont uno de los primeros un
ping pong uno tiene las manos dispuestas
para estar jugando en el tablero a este
tenis de mesa el problema es que por
cada pelota que remos por cada tiro que
no podamos atrapar la segunda mano que
esté ubicada en el traveler va a recibir
un castigo se queman esas latigazos
este juego está en exposición en el
museo de berlín como un desarrollo
contemporáneo de artistas trabajando con
videojuegos en el límite de lo ético en
el límite del juego en el límite del
arte pero de eso se trata de provocar
los límites
y es importante tener en cuenta que
todas estas propuestas están retomando
el valor del juego en lo que capas
habíamos dejado del lado que
considerábamos que era de niños chinos
de niños el juego también es cosa de
grandes el juego puede ser serio el
juego sentó las bases de todas las
culturas y las sociedades el juego nos
hace socializar nos hace conectarnos con
el otro y el juego de la mano del arte
se puede tomar ciertas libertades puede
explorar puede experimentar puede
arriesgarse ser irreverente proponer
nuevas experiencias abrir puertas de eso
se trata de esto de estar atento de no
quedarnos cómodos en nuestros lugares
añorando tiempos pasados y mejores donde
entendíamos todo lo que veíamos de no
quedarnos con el personaje de woody
allen medianoche en parís soñando con
viajar en el tiempo y darnos cuenta que
alrededor nuestro están empezando a ver
cambios que depende de nosotros
despertar esa curiosidad interna cambiar
la mirada volver a ver
que hay cambios de paradigmas que se
están sucediendo que los videojuegos son
una de las posibles caras y quizás es
una forma fácil de acercarse a este
campo los invito a volver a jugar